[Music]
[Music]
nazi [ __ ] juicy
poor kids are just as bright and just as
talon's white kid president trump and
the democrats around demagogues around
the world but i tell him if you have a
problem figuring out whether you're for
me or trump then you ain't black we
choose truth over facts
i want to be clear
i'm not going nuts
did you ever hear that legend of that
spooky dude
in cities across america
they whisper his name
his name something like uh
like a candy
rumor has it if you say his name in a
mirror five times he appears yeah you
say his name five times in the mirror
comes out and kills you one two three
four four
candy ass
hi
wait hold on a second
aren't you just that fat balding guy on
cnn
yes it is i heterosexual news anchor
brian steltzer
who can take an agenda
cover it in news
sprinkle it with lies and some
misinformation to
the candy ass
the candies
oh god no
i like girls
some believed it was just a fairy tale
but they were wrong candy ass
what's so ooh about it you're next
twinkle toes
no one be safe
candy ass
ooh
this one's for you
oh
i don't come for girls
only women are safe
you don't have a brother do you
[Music]
candy ass
coming soon
unless you're female
[Laughter]
[Music]
dot com
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
speedy
[Music]
okay i'm not out of breath
good i just had to run out and run back
in really well you know this i was
standing for for you watching here right
now i had to run out and i ran back in
this is uh this is a big show i was
watching cnn sorry i was just engrossed
wow i'm amazed that you're still awake
we're going to be talking about scene i
don't know it's brian stelter going to
be fired what oh according to brian
stelter oh fingers crossed so uh
we have a lot to get to today look
russia ukraine i know it's one of those
situations where you feel like there can
be overload yeah you can just leave over
there angela thank you appreciate it uh
you feel like it's overload but there is
something going on right now that is
concerning a lot of people missing uh
we're gonna be talking about it is
driving russia into the arms of china
who by the way are not natural allies
if you don't wipe someone out militarily
i'm not saying we should uh but you just
put on these economic sanctions we kind
of know what happens if you try to
browbeat someone on the international
stage economically yeah especially
somebody like treaty oversight no well
come on journey everything they had to
pay it back
they take it seriously they take it
seriously so but of course this is
trump's fault if you hear mitt romney
tell her sure yep mitt romney useless to
the left and the right so we'll be
talking about that also be talking about
the fact that uh well
price shelter is going to be fired and i
don't know if you know this but they're
developing a vaccine that can spread a
contagious
vaccine yeah
so uh
let me ask you this that's the best
thing you can do for the algorithm if
you're watching but if you're watching
this archive is comment below so
question of the day we're going to have
a few of them today
do you think russia will ever actually
use nuclear weapons
do you think there's any intent or do
you think it's bluffing this is
something that people are discussing
right now and they look i think you know
the answer but apparently they don't
know cnn they have 15 different voices
on this morning with 15 different
opinions well of course i think maybe
accidentally on themselves could be an
answer so right yes they were like oh we
launched at ukraine oh we shouldn't have
used acme nukes just come right back to
us i live long enough did not have
warranty service plan i live to ripe old
age of 38 which in this this area is
very good we live on vodka in indiana
these four reincarnations for russia we
got to chernobyl like oh oh no
does my thyroid look swollen yeah
it says my twin he's behind me literally
yes yes
we are attached i'll turn around i've
never seen back to i've never seen
stomach to spine twin we have many in
russia
so uh best thing you can do by the way
too is if we're not allowed on youtube
anymore especially as we talk about the
vaccines today that's one of those
touchy subjects right you can tune in on
rumble or mug club live
monday through thursday at 10 a.m
eastern nothing will make me happier
than to see you go over there we have
another hour of show today also tomorrow
live fact checking the state of the
union address no idea how long that will
be right so we won't be there in the
morning tomorrow but we'll do the
evening show right not doing double duty
come on guys no and i think there might
be something going up wednesday morning
that's a pretty in-depth video about uh
let's see yeah
yeah we don't necessarily know yeah
what don't worry it's about i got that
okay i'll tease it for you uh
i have no idea how what was written
by me under an alias as a clear parody
was uh accepted as academic research but
it was and we have it all filled
and it's the silly better the silliest
crap you could possibly imagine just in
case you had any faith left in the
institution of higher education so i
don't know if it's going up wednesday
but it's an undercover thing whenever it
goes up period yeah either way we're
getting sued by an angry fat lesbian
whale okay
before
yeah which one
you mean
you mean uh the entire uh schenectady
college professor yes take a number
ladies yes
oh before i go gerald how are you i'm
well how are you doing i'm doing fine
i'm uh good and uh dave landau is here
you know him you love him when we're
talking away how are you sir good man
how about you i'm okay a little less
sleep but uh i'm good all right what
happens you don't ever sleep why do you
i know it's a problem yeah yeah it
should be normal if you just say i slept
if it's something new yes exactly if
it's atypical just update us you'll be
like oh i slept eight hours it was crazy
like what or it's like i slept three
hours from the shakes and night terrors
were like we know yeah normally okay you
know what unlockable i used to get
really bad like actual night terrors oh
yeah yep really bad night terrors i
haven't had them in a while i don't know
did credence play and you hear copters
yes
no i just had a night tear that was i
was perpetually at a creed concert i
owned my home
robot open i'm like stop was it like out
of body crowd surfing right yeah it
couldn't wake up but my wife had to take
the gun away at that point on earth like
take the gun away because even in the
night terry can still hit the palm safe
go to shoot it's just another chord
[Laughter]
i like this end of the scene i missed
can you take me ha ha ha ha ha ha holds
the r longer
the worst gun ever
almost as bad as our nuke where is this
oh no we need stricter manufacturing
standards where's creed nuke we've said
no more creed kalashnikovs what you want
creed nuke or bushnuck both sounds same
yes
we also have nickelback moab yes no one
do that that's too much no no put audio
sleeve revolver back i don't like
ukraine i don't hate
so speaking of higher education and this
infiltration that we did which i'm
excited to release um
right now let's show the results of uh
public education here in the united
states uh
look i don't want this to start as
depressing off the bat but
look
it's called being an adult
and that means sometimes accepting
realities that you don't like and this
is reality yo sola high school had a
walk out today and this lilit girl had
said this
i am so glad
that years ago dr martin luther king the
first black man ended slavery because if
not people will be whipped every day
well
there you go
it's the thought that counts
they're trying right did you can we play
that again because people may have
missed is the black girl's reaction
yeah everyone in the crowd was like uh
uh
but
we should we should send them back into
school yes yeah but then they'll just
come out with more of this watch the
black girl's reaction you can see it in
real time watch what yo solo high school
had a walk out today and this lilit girl
had said this
i am so glad
that years ago dr martin luther king the
first black man ending sleep here's the
reaction here's the
oh no uh-oh
people are putting down cameras and
signs they're like this isn't the right
field
you were only off by like
75-85 years something like that you go
to martin luther king junior high
at the corner of martin luther king jr
and malcolm x boulevard yeah and wrong
century that is bad
did you don't you learn
wow i'm so glad my kid's in private
school yes if my son said that i would
never hit a child but i might no but
then you hear john oliver talk about the
real problem is charter schools because
it's for profit
sure gosh you mean they have educational
standards that they have to uphold yeah
you mean uh maybe teachers get fired if
one student thinks that martin luther
king jr was the first human
the first person oh yeah i love paying
tons of money to send my kid to a
private school because they're not doing
the job at the other schools right yeah
it's the one that i already pay taxes
for right yeah this is free yeah
thrilling that was my idea that you
wanted to mask them on zoom calls right
double mask them and put up glass files
well yes yeah you're gonna share the
screen all day don't worry they're not
gonna go into minecraft or mario kart at
any point during this right yeah they
muscle something with the civil rights
act i don't know i don't know i may go
to uh let me go watch pewdiepie
that's how you it's not just that she
said that it's that she made it to the
podium well that's true she was the best
and brightest among them yeah
she's the navy seal of uh you know
public education byproducts
she thought it was martin luffa the rest
of them and she's like no guys it's
martin luther i got this someone's
tackling her that's that that's what i'm
that's what i scrub my ass with that's
not a human martin it's a luffa yeah a
coral reef and [ __ ]
[Laughter]
when martin luther king came over
wait no what oh my god i want to go back
to height i've said this before i want
to go back to school like billy madison
yeah and get the 4.0 i deserve it
i would have aced every
test if that is the standard yeah
anymore dave when harriet tubman helped
the slaves escape
on the pinta the santa maria
and the malcolm x
down that boulevard yep
they were amtrak
i don't think any of that is correct
yeah are you sure 1492 rosa parks sailed
the ocean blue that's right at the front
of the ship that's right the roughest
part though yeah like get off that and
that was arma style and then she killed
all them engines with kobe blankets
[Laughter]
don't you question me i'm cultural i got
a dream catcher in my car and [ __ ]
look at that hanging from the mirror and
one tattooed on my thigh like a lot of
strippers i can't figure that out it
doesn't look like you caught a dream at
all
looks like your dream is dead yeah you
know but i don't know why i'm planning
to fall asleep at the wheel it's kind of
a dick move
[Laughter]
yeah that's what yeah you know it always
makes me feel great when i see a dream
catcher hanging from the mirror and an
ambient bobble head on the dashboard oh
yeah it's like clearly yeah
um
no they made bobble heads that's yeah
weird well they do yeah it's it's not
good hey what's that are those is that
what happened to your blinker button oh
i changed it to a lunesta dispenser
butterfly that's why i can go drive to
taco bell and get
i'm high on biases five pounds of
diazepines at three a.m and not know i
ate us that's my favorite hold on i
gotta give a speech about civil rights
i'll be back
well i guess you know what to be fair
she might have taken notes from our
former vice president
you got the first
sort of
mainstream african-american yeah
who was articulate and bright and and
clean and nice looking guy
i mean this that's a storybook man yeah
well he could have just ended it first
clean
i could have just
said anything yeah yeah that's pretty
tough it's like if you want to say like
articulate and it's like
all right but then clean ah you know
what there's no way around that one i
always look for some way to defend what
somebody meant yeah like the good and
i'm
partway and i'm like there's just
there's not even a paul no there's not
you have to be a beautiful mind to
figure out what he meant yes okay
he's like a shark he can't move
backwards he can't back up his mistakes
he just keeps going further he talks
himself into a corner and then just
keeps ramming into a corner like a
bumper car i think i can get out
man that's articulate that's good joe
yeah thanks joe thank you for that
appreciate it and by the way that's the
reason that barack obama made him vice
president
because he was like now if i if i pick
if i pick the most racist man
and what i don't just mean as an
implication i mean unilaterally agreed
upon as the most racist human being
alive
let's be clear i think i'm tolerant as a
president if you shoot me
that's what you're gonna get no you
don't want it i promise that's why
that's that that not not now let me
that's why they call them joe fire
insurance
but that was a 90 chest so we just
didn't even see it yeah it was 90 chests
like wow you know what he's uh he's
better than the alternative i remember
when he said in his first speech he said
in his first speech yeah uh
and ever and not not no not everyone
knows you don't mess with joke it's like
so that's projecting it's you're this is
reverse psychology because that's all
you do with everything yeah yeah there's
no purp he serves no purpose oh he's not
to be messed with he knows the first
black president you're taking a risk yes
and he knew that was a bargaining chip
right yeah you impeach me you get joe
and boy was he right
yeah now who's who's after uh who's
after in line for hillary clinton and
then uh robert byrd oh i think uh
gig's up
which do you see joe asked you it's
crazy
i love it kamala i don't i don't even
take her calls yeah kidding me he called
tmz and paparazzi when he was installing
the wheelchair ramp for joe he's like to
the white house i think yep there you go
there you go he was [ __ ] his pants
in 08.
no no no now dial in your scopes for
about 300
[Laughter]
it years a little little what does it
call those little elevator chairs oh the
pudding dispenser no
what are those chairs
wheelchair chairs
yeah it goes up uh oh what do you call
yeah it kills you
yeah
i hope that doesn't happen yeah well i
guarantee you joe would get stuck oh
yeah he's right right in the middle
just halfway or just be a trail of brown
down the stairs two buttons like oh my
gosh why is he late for the state of the
union uh he spent the last nine hours on
the wheelchair electric wheelchair ramp
yeah thank god he was buckled in yeah
swept on a brick of parmesan cheese
walking into his house yes
or guns hidden in the trash
all right so here's something else too
before we move on to russian uh louis
c.k has canceled the february shows in
uh in kiev
well okay
yeah i mean i would hope i appreciate it
but thanks for the layup they need humor
because of bombs ah yeah yeah yeah
something about a russian invasion i
have no idea wolverines forever
something like that uh so tickets were
actually being they were sold at a 30
percent discount really but he still
just canceled them who's the idiot that
was buying them at 30 percent rush is
about to invade he's like we should use
comedy it's good oh that throws assets
this will be new currency shows to
serial masturbator who's canceled
america
so um it's a great idea and actually i
think over the weekend um he uh louis
c.k was talking about this uh was is it
is it i think they're actually i don't
know oh they're reading it now on cnn oh
[Music]
okay
well flitzer
i got this one
hello is this louis ck yeah
hi
we have reports that your show in kiev
is going ahead as scheduled in spite of
the invasion i am way
not in the ukraine that is the exact
opposite of where i am
i can't get a flight
you try to take off and they kill you
but it was reported on twitter that the
shows were going ahead as scheduled oh
holy [ __ ]
some [ __ ] me with his iphone and
you're like i guess that's just the
thing that's happening now
as of the other day there were no
changes on the venue's website
because the guy whose job that is is
dead now
he's erased from existence for eternity
we don't know that
he could be in a fallout shelter from
the 50s huddle around a bunch of dirty
little kids and old ladies and shawls
going oh wait i have to tell everyone
he's not coming they're like oh darn now
i don't get to step over a pile of dead
bodies to see a fat piece of
who everyone hates now
well where are you
amsterdam
what is the mood on the ground there
no one gives a sh
everyone's just high in shooting
packages into syphilitic hookers it
doesn't matter
well i guess that's all i have to know
we can wrap this up
are you seriously
this is just who i am as a person i
can't help it
oh no that's okay i just thought i was
the only one doing it
this is cnn the most trusted name in
news
do you have to be a sex offender to work
at cnn i think it's part of the what is
funny is yeah one of those people are
canceled for actually being a sex
offender one of those people are
actually a sex offender yeah one of them
got a contract extension before it was
up yeah you got to lock this guy down
otherwise we don't want msnbc to have
him look at the talent on that man we'll
give you points on the back end one guy
brilliant comedian who got permission
from someone other guy actual man who
masturbated during a phone call and we
just pretended well when he came back on
air dave in in their defense they had a
woman interview him and asked him these
questions oh awkward at all it was
really awkward at the end of that
interview when he tried to put a sticky
note on the camera at cnn like yeah that
doesn't work here yeah like allison i
was looking at you the whole time right
wouldn't you just close your computer
wouldn't you just unplug everything
wouldn't you have one for i don't know
cnn and one for your hobby something
else maybe wouldn't you just have a
shred of self-control well that too
start you know like we can't wait 30
minutes
it's not like this was a two-hour zoom
call it wasn't like a crazy it was just
like it was like it was a catch-up
meeting yeah maybe it just took so long
he's like oh no i lost track of time
where are my pants that's the problem
with the internet because before that
you didn't walk into a conference room
or like okay we have coffee water and
stop masturbating at the conference
table yeah
sorry i didn't realize you saw me of
course we can see you you're right there
we're in ballroom b at the marriott and
you're in front of me
it's called ballroom yeah oh is that not
is that not what it is anymore we're
just naming things nebulously sorry
pardon me for putting them on a chair
yeah is that because of society yes
tuban it's because of society just stop
who's the guy they wanted to hire
outside of tune like who was who's plan
b and they were like no let's just bring
tubin back uh i don't know but we'll
talk about stellar in a little bit so uh
before we move on we also have the biden
supreme court nominee if you've been
following us he nominated uh i don't
know how it's going to be kentaji brown
jackson i've only read it i've not heard
it spoken because the story only makes
me mad that's close to the supreme court
which brings us to this
weeks or days there are probably quite a
few of the these this week with stating
curious coincidences
[Music]
is it ketanji or kataji i don't know if
this is pronounced but i think it should
okay i have no idea i think so uh well
brown jackson let's go with that
miss jackson
[Laughter]
that was the whitest version of that
ever
brown jackson
jackson brown same judge oh yeah
right now that's the blackest version
ever why'd you why'd you pick this
supreme court nominee running on empty
running now just love her music like
what do you think about brown jackson
she's a [ __ ] girl and that's enough
that's enough
now we're down to just one biracial and
i think it's oats
[Laughter]
so
rich girl
[Laughter]
gotta itch girl now
that's because don't by the way don't
use public toilets uh same judge who uh
sentenced the pizzagate shooter in case
you have forgotten about this uh so
another interesting that's the greatest
qualification for uh brown jackson
that's that's our biggest case huh do
you think this person was just selected
on the name like jackson that's a black
sounding name what's the middle name
brown done this is perfect
uh another interesting point too about
this shooting i don't know about pizza
pizzagate um the shooter only shot at a
closet with a computer inside that's all
he actually shot and for all the hub of
about pizzagate you know you would think
it was this massive
scale shooting but he only shot at a
closet with a computer inside which also
why would there be it why would you need
a closet with a computer
inside it
at a pizza parlor
and what was stelter coming out of it
this has been curious coincidences
[Music]
brian selter only leaves the closet for
brunching yeah he goes back in when he's
done brunch i leave for brunching i saw
my shadow six more weeks of mimosas i'll
be back for lunch
and then second lunch yes third
you said it was all you could eat and a
midnight snack you know what let's just
put a fridge in my closet and then din
dessert yes
maybe like a hot plate you're like
college kind of college dorm vibe going
midnight snacksies not co-ed ooh gross
[Laughter]
super straight so by the way before we
move on and talk about brian stelter uh
dave and i are on tour yeah you can live
with credit.com tour we'll be in tulsa
oklahoma may 14th and then colorado
springs june 18th so tulsa oklahoma may
14th june 18th colorado springs and uh
yeah just doing uh doing the good old
stand-up live credit.com tour all right
so get it now did you hear about so
brian stelter so there's some changes
coming up at uh at cnn right now here's
what's interesting is not only that
brian selter is afraid of being fired
but the reason he's afraid of being
fired so not what you would think bad
reporting not doing your job well
being unappealing in the face yeah you
know what let's go see you can do you
can ziggs that i can zag he just gave
away you don't give away the
the thing yeah the twist
oh nobody saw that twist coming
yeah thanks
they called it's gerald m knight
so fired for being too handsome yeah
that's the twist brian selter at the end
of it and he finds out
i was a gay ghost all along oh no
you're too much of a man's man we need
somebody lighter ladies you know we've
had too many comparisons we've done our
focus groups with frank luntz and they
see you when they just see charles
bronson yes we don't know we're too
you're a much of a clint eastwood yes
yes that's what they say
we need more of uh i don't know uh
a fruity grimace yes yes exactly we need
more of a dom deluise type do you know
anyone mr stelter who would be
a dead ringer for a dom de louise but
more suspect yes yes
[Laughter]
leave it to the imagination so
upcoming changes at cnn and uh this guy
who's going to be the new head of cnn
outgoing jeff zucker it was leaked chris
licht is his name stop with the jokes
okay actually you know what comment
below your best licked joke but is it
true
you have my attention now you have my
curiosity
mr licht i'm here for smith
chris lichtsteiner i have my own green
room but i'd be willing to share
so
it's a large screen
double-wide trailer really
i also have a trough
it's just the men's bathroom yes it's
just giant chair in it and the trough is
the urinal
we put ice in there we can melt it it's
fun it's hard to pee while sitting down
though people think it's gross to eat as
much as i do in the men's room but i do
what i do yeah you know it's that
actually i don't know if this is more
bacteria in the kitchen than the men's
room so really i'm more sanitary than
you yeah and by men's room i mean my
closet which is also a men's room
it's a water closet what you've never
been to europe
peep the handbag so chris licht has
announced as a new head of cnn okay
here's the thing it was leaked it
clearly seems to be a deliberate leak
because it's accurate yeah and brian
stelter
didn't know about it so they didn't let
him know the name of his show
is reliable sources here you go
and now we know who's azlov is selected
to run cnn once it happens
chris licht will be the head of news for
the newly combined company according to
three sources who spoke with me on
saturday now the appointment has not
been officially announced yet but it
will be special in the coming days the
website puck broke the news
we now know yes we've known yes thank
you i was spoken to on saturday yep no
brunch
my meal with my chicken here at reliable
if you if you're not even breaking
anything what do you what do you what is
it you would say you do
here
so i'm called reliable sources unlike
your show right yeah okay so to give you
a couple of things here that are
important so chris licht is going to be
ahead of cnn okay uh he also you know
discovers purchase cnn i believe
and he wants to uh bring cnn's credible
feedback so that's his main concern he
wants to get rid of what seemed what
seems to be partisan hackery
which is interesting because he was
actually um the creator of uh or one of
the creators of morning joe
and then uh he is currently i believe
the show runner or one of the top
producers for the late show with stephen
colbert so look you know where he lines
up okay you know where this chris lick
lines up yeah so what he's saying when
he says we want to uh retrieve from the
uh abyss the
you know the credibility of cnn what he
really means is they want to go back to
lying to you by omission a lot of people
are now saying oh cnn got really bad no
no they didn't get really bad you just
weren't aware of it sometimes you'll
hear people like joe rogan say this
you'll hear people who are sort of newly
conservative right red pilled and they
go i used to really you know cnn used to
be reliable they were never reliable you
just weren't paying attention
they've always been this bad anderson
cooper has always been this bad just to
be clear don lemon has been there for
years and years this is not a new
development
so this guy clearly is he wants to go
back to the period of bias by by
omission and cnn really has gotten to be
more opinion journalism um so that's the
important point to note on that front
now here's something else that's funny
brian stelter is now afraid of being
fired now it's not that that's hilarious
but it is it's the subtext this is
reported by red state uh and uh i don't
i can't confirm the authenticity but i'm
pretty sure so it says uh brian seltzer
who spent most of his last half decade
trying to cost other several people
their jobs has told people that he
thinks he's going to lose his job at cnn
so what does that tell you okay you have
a new incoming head of cnn all right who
wants to at least keep up the appearance
of objective journalism
that means there was a meeting look
they're going to be some changes here at
cnn we want to uh you know really get
back to delivering real accurate news oh
my god i'm fired
i lose everything oh my god morning
joe's coming back
what if i do a show called afternoon jab
yes
no
mid-evening poke
how about dinner stab
night time in search
no perhaps um perhaps some early morning
prodding nothing well no just grab my
things just a pair of crocs
and a cape that he's been trying to make
work yeah i just don't know what does
this work no it doesn't i'll take it
with me then it doesn't that belongs to
wardrobe no foiled again now speaking of
they're putting they're putting them up
right now oh my gosh don't put on them
don't put it on the side profile let's
see what brian they're saying right now
live let's see if it's not just complete
part of the network networks but access
to the internet is an alternative that
provides access to frankly the truth the
ground truth of what's going on at the
same time we are seeing some russian
websites being hacked there are multiple
reports of russian media websites being
hacked with anti-food and messages
posted on them in the past his profile
looks like he should be wearing shower
shoes before and execution
those kinds of hacks also signs that
putin's losing this information war
on one level that's true on another
level about the headline they're really
nervous
zelensky is winning the pr battle
ukraine winning the pr battle that may
be less important than it is that's
important than the physical warfare on
the ground but it is critical around the
world you know here's the thing every i
really hate the anti-americanism that
you see across the globe especially
having visited europe yeah but every now
and then you just see an american like
okay they're not they've got a point
yeah they're seeing him in the airport
when they land
i'd be pissed too imagine the country
that invented the guillotine looking at
that like yeah there's no way to make it
fit right i don't have a guillotine for
uh whatever
what you call it mcdonald's this fat
purple clown there is nine weeks lead
time for custom stocks i don't know what
it is i don't care i need a tin head
basket please yes
why uh why does the man witch from dune
have to be beheaded
you can't kill him he died he just rises
up
he's on the ceiling and you're like ah
but it just shows this is look
how he views himself brian stelter
and it's not even true that they're
going to have objective journalism at
cnn but the moment brian selter believed
that they were going to attempt
objective journalism he's like oh i'll
lose everything i thought he was out
he's like yes i'll do the morning show
bring me up and it's one thing to be
looking i don't i don't you know i mean
this guy has made his living trying to
get people fired but
i don't it's one thing for somebody to
be fired
it's another thing to be brian stelter
and be fired from broadcast television
who else on god's green earth is going
to put this man back on tv and a lot of
people knows like he basically rose to
fame because he was sort of like a perez
hilton for a politic like a political
blog website a gossip website basically
so then he got a job at like the new
york times and and uh i believe it was
new york times going by wrote here and
it was because they were surprised that
he was a college student writing this
but here's the thing so he sort of
i hate was back jordan by his appearance
yeah the students or is it wow that is
right yeah they only figured out after
he had a two-year contract and they were
a year and a half like what they're like
you're 22. 22. i thought you were about
to die
the only reason we filed the extension
um so i got an insurance policy on you
it was a soft text it was a soft
expectations of him being young yeah and
then he got on cnn and now they say okay
but now you're a 36 year old
uh completely super straight uh
broadcaster with the lowest ratings you
are entirely useless to us yeah he is
proven to be a failed commodity that's
gotta be a really scary thought for
brian stelter and frankly i don't want
him gone no no i was just about to bring
up that point like he is perfectly
positioned there because if they're
trying to go back and rehab their image
which sucks in the first place brian
stelter being front and center
hussain you don't want to create that
power
vacuum perfect position for him is all
forced but yeah well that's um that's
what i think i think you're right
yeah well what where is he gonna he got
there though because he basically got
everyone fired look at him yes i mean
it's just karma you can't just keep
cutting through everything until you're
to the top they're eventually going to
get rid of it and then he even threw
people under the bus who were fired at
his network yes like chris was
struggling for his spot he that day he
was like he's a rapist yeah you heard it
here first yes he's a rapist and boy i
don't know who's gonna fill that nine
o'clock
oh boy they're like no it's not gonna
happen well it was worth a shot i'll
take my cape yeah cuomo hadn't even
packed his things when he's in there
measuring for drapes yeah cuomo's seat
leaves and he just hovers
yeah
uncle aunt
anyway you guys let us i i i don't want
stelter to go away best thing you can do
for the youtube algorithm
i actually want him to stick around i
really really do i know we should just
hire him save brian stelter let's start
oh okay go fund me might be the funniest
gag of all time if we just pay him a lot
of money to be in his third chair and we
just and you just don't let him speak
you just duct tape his mouth could just
oh we just he has to say only extremist
things yes
nearly offensive and we're like brian
stelter that's wow
just say that i can't believe i mean we
have jews who work here i mean come on
and then i'll be like we don't
and he always has to hold his purse in
the chat yeah and he'll like shake it
yes
every now and then when you tell an
off-color joke he has to go dave hit you
with the purse
and then there's a laugh track yeah yes
well we would be we would need a laugh
check we'd be here no he'll be he'll be
just like maude yeah
be sure to be sure to be dressed like a
stella getty
golden girls we would uh we need to get
a uh we need to get a oh that's
commercial yeah no no you'll need a love
seat yes
that chair's not rated i call it a me
seat yes
okay full of love so here's another
thing too that's been happening before
we get to russia and gerald really has
been following russia and china very
closely and and it is interesting and
unfortunately this was always my concern
and i know you and elaine were arguing
about
russia and what we should do and a
friendly debate it was
i i think it's it's everyone's heart out
there breaks for the people of the
ukraine yeah but two things can be true
you can feel that way and also believe
that we shouldn't be sending americans
over there to die yeah and that being
said you can recognize those two things
and also understand that the actions
that are currently being taken
economically in the world stage could be
driving russia into the arms of china
but before that uh of course conspiracy
theorists have been heckled by the media
quite a bit um for suggesting that
coveted vaccines and this was i don't
know if it was last week wasn't too long
ago but it's been going on for a while
for suggesting the covet vaccines could
shed
to unvaxed people potentially it's even
been fact checked one influencer
claiming that just being around someone
who's been vaccinated causes those side
effects that not only can the covet 19
vaccines hurt women's fertility by
attacking the placenta they cause a
vaccinated person to shed the virus onto
women and affect their periods or
pregnancies so the first part as i
reported here on fact check friday
before the wh says it's not true the
vaccines cannot
cause true infertility about those
who've been vaccinated shedding virus
particles and causing harm to others i
have found no scientific document or
source that says it's even possible with
the mrna vaccines or the j and j vaccine
okay now
it's not true yet and what they just
said is accurate there is no scientific
document available right with the did
you say pfizer in jnj vaccine well mnra
nra
throwing the ends in the wrong place
again the point is that is not
inaccurate but what they trying to do is
act like it's one person said oh i said
no this isn't just one person who
believed that there is a potential for
shedding or one person said this and we
haven't found any scientific literature
on these specific vaccines understood
i'm not fact checking that i'm talking
about the spirit of how they do this and
this is what they'll be doing at cnn
right it's the lies by omission it's
take an extremist fringe person to make
a point that in another context might be
valid or worth investigation right to
dismiss it and then uh selectively
present references that uh make your
case for you and by the way that's why
we present all references they're
available at lotus credit.com if you're
watching on youtube it's in that pinned
comment and of course if you're watching
on rumble or mug club which i recommend
you do you can just go to the website
and hit that tab so
here's the interesting part have you
read about this the researchers and now
in uh in the u.s the uk and australia
are now researching the possibility of a
quote self-spreading vaccine i'm going
to read this to you the unvaccinated
would quote catch the vaccine as it
spreads rapidly across the country in
airborne droplets passed on via close
contact with others
just as colds and flu
already spread and we actually have
exclusive footage of the preliminary
results with the um self uh shedding
vaccine trials
[Music]
well that seems pretty cut and dry oh
yeah it's worked before we're going to
do it to ourselves aren't we yeah this
is yeah this is yeah i mean what go to
the top of a shopping mall with guns yes
with woody harrelson just hang out
this is a scary thought well it's funny
the yet that we threw on there was kind
of a joke but it's not a joke because
every single time some claim like this
gets made and they're like ah it's
absolutely not possible for this to
happen and then we're like oh that was
man that was only like six months
part of that getting a vaccine i feel is
knowing the side effects per person and
talking to your doctor you know on a
private basis knowing how that would
affect you individually
not just catching it walking down the
street the same as
anything right that seems extremely
vicious no i think you're absolutely
right not only that there is not eight
now of course side effects uh and
adverse reactions with vaccines are very
rare in most cases yes there are more
side effects you know
mrna injections and all other i'm
pro-vex i just don't think you should
catch no exactly they're very rare but i
don't know of a single vaccine
that doesn't affect certain individuals
negatively with adverse effects
particularly things like neurological
conditions gbs is one of them there are
certain people who cannot even take a
basic flu shot because of autoimmune
issues people thinking jenny mccarthy's
an author right yes exactly and i don't
know how the difference said that no but
it did
so people this is a concern people who
absolutely from their doctors recommend
upon their doctor's recommendation
cannot take vaccines don't have a choice
in the matter
and this is what's happened to think
about this we've done this with
everything else we're big pharma bad
right people talk about big blue they
were they were uh you know villain du
jour for a long time except in this
instance we've done the same thing with
medicine drugs opioids bad yeah okay uh
benzodiazepine is bad okay uh even
people you know ibuprofen bad anti
everything you know drugs bad you should
take these and then for some reason
though when it relates to the vaccine
it's no this is good yeah this is all
this is good for everybody i don't know
any other medical intervention that is
considered
good for everybody as a matter of fact i
don't think you can find one and when
you're talking about something that
would be spreading or shedding
that's now putting that hands the power
in the hands of government and of course
it's not only an infringement of
personal liberty i'm just wondering
where all the people who were skeptical
of big pharma and all the people who
were talking about my body my choice
went to i don't think it could be more
clear than this it's not like abortion
where you know you believe abortion up
until nine months and including birth
period now i'm not creating a straw man
that's the actual policy of many leftist
states to be clear i don't know where
the folks have gone
no i have no idea too and we when we
talk about the
the issues that we had earlier on with
the vaccine it wasn't that we were just
making claims right some some french
people were like saying all right make
my cousin's balls swell if everybody
remembers that right yeah that wasn't
necessarily it was the that was cardi b
yeah i know we were mega nostalgia one
of them
they kind of blend i don't know who's
the other one yeah no that that was uh
no the problem we had was that clearly a
race thing and not a six-inch nail slash
challenge thing well yes yeah we just
didn't have any long-term studies
because it hadn't been around long
enough to have any long-term studies
yeah generally that helps long-term
studies require something being around
long-term well look at it we're at about
what a year year and a half right now
and we're going huh we didn't know and
it's like really this is all we were
saying from the beginning is like hey
maybe just do some studies on this that
go a little bit longer than say i don't
know a few months yeah
look either you have to be blindly
trusting of authority across the board
or you have to be skeptical across the
board doesn't mean you have to agree
with someone else who's a skeptic across
the board but i don't understand how
people go from being a skeptic
particularly as it relates to big pharma
particularly as it relates to drug
companies and then it's completely gone
i that's it's about consistent i'm not
required to suspend my consistency to
say uh hold on a second is this a good
idea though is it a good idea for every
single individual
it's entirely consistent it is
inconsistent for someone to say big
pharma we have problems with these lobby
it's one of the most powerful lobbying
groups in all of washington dc is big
firm i i don't disagree with you there i
also believe that western medicine is
great yeah if you have cancer and you're
chewing on kashanga root your [ __ ] out
of luck
but i'm still skeptical of every drug
and i believe that every person should
have the right to choose i believe that
we should have more drugs available to
people and i believe that the fda
approval process there's too much red
tape obviously it's a problem that if
someone understands the risks they
should be allowed to take that drug that
is entirely consistent with that person
should also be allowed to not take that
drug
when you see the policy of the left
right these are the same people who said
all every single democrat and every
single member of joe biden's cabinet
said either the vaccine could not
possibly happen on donald trump's
timeline right
or that they would not trust the vaccine
or they wouldn't take the vaccine almost
all of them said all three and they said
it publicly on the record you can go
back and just search well on youtube
search on mug club because you won't
find it on youtube you can see that this
is something that joe biden himself said
kamala harris well it's unrealistic for
it to happen at this time i wouldn't
trust the vaccine because it happened
under trump and i wouldn't take the
vaccine all of that is gone now yeah
all of it
just asking that we'd be consistent
especially as it relates to people's
private medical decisions and what you
put in your own body
okay
now we can move on to uh uh former vice
president joe biden the ukraine what's
going on here with russia in the ukraine
um
no one's paying closer attention by the
way should be noted than former vice
president joe biden is he really yeah
he's just a hawk wow really well he
always has been yeah well when he sleeps
it's when he focuses best right he's on
it faster than a duck on a june buck
they
poke him with a stick every few minutes
and let him know the what's what right
why is there a mirror hanging above his
mouth
i don't know same reason there's a
mirror hanging above brian stelter's
closet bed no i don't think that's the
same
[Laughter]
walk in is that one of those fun house
mirrors no it's just me i said the whole
ceiling with mirrors i look like someone
hit expand on my body and never hit the
shift key
oh this this is my mirror slash crying
room
mirror mirror on the wall shut up okay
all right you're still fat brian
you're the weakest of them
well i guess i understand
how do you still have a job all right
he's not healed yet so here's the thing
though why would former vice president
joe biden be so interested
in the ukraine why is he paying such
close attention could it be
they were walking out to prescott said
no i said i'm not gonna
or we're not gonna give you the billion
dollars they said you have no authority
you're not the president the president
said i said call him
i said i'm telling you you're not
getting a billion dollars
i said you're not getting the billion
i'm going to be leaving here and i think
it was about six hours i looked i said
i'm leaving in six hours if the
prosecutor's not fired you're not
getting the money
oh son of a [ __ ]
got fired
oh he was talking about the other guy
oh that's weird also that's not a crime
to brag about it too on the record it's
highly illegal
just to be clear yeah just
i was being uh sarcastic yeah that's a
crime
oh you mean irregular no i don't no no
no i don't frowned upon illegal felony
jail time ah
agree to disagree we don't nope mcgruff
would be upset yeah that's only you can
take a bite out of biden former vice
president and also just to be one thing
that a lot of people don't know is at
hunter and obviously had his issues with
ukraine after he got out of trouble with
ukraine uh and i believe we have an
exclusive he had an emergency visit to a
doctor for uh parmesan cheese nose
my nose is so stuffed it's just got to
be covered well your test came back
negative for covid but your your nasal
cavities are clogged with parmesan
cheese i swear i thought it was cocaine
good for you uh let's try clear hunter
eggs clear
yes it's it's made by clear ink which is
recognized as the leading manufacturer
of xylitol based products in north
america and uh this nasal spray is all
natural all natural what does that mean
uh well that it's drug-free
that sucks
parmesan is also drug-free just try the
spray
wow
i can breathe right breathing is
important for a person most that person
has dirt on you right
wow
uh let's just be glad that it worked all
right sure did
thanks for showing me the clear way doc
it's my pleasure can you do one more
favor for me
sure
hold on to this laptop for me
uh no
no
deal all right how about a
quick prescription of 200 percent get
out of my office
all right i got some good at home
i i told you to quit smoking gouda
now
speaking of consistency wonderful
sponsors and they become a sponsor to
the show because they heard me talking
about them yeah it's a product that i've
used uh you uh can actually go it's uh
clear.com and clear with an x and the
reason is because it uses something
called xylitol in there now i encourage
you to do your own research go to the
website you can go to pubmed and read
the actual approved data uh clinical
trials clinical studies that have shown
that this actually cleans out your nasal
cavity like reduces the adhesion factor
for things like covalent viruses right
in your nasal cavity like 99 you know
you think about it you brush your teeth
you take a shower yeah think of all the
crap you're breathing in are you what
are you doing to clean this especially
around dave yeah i mean if it works for
hunter and this is
this is doctor recommended what i mean
by that is some doctors yes i would
never say all doctors is like a
self-shedding vaccine
no so i wouldn't be so bold even though
it's drug-free and uh works for doctors
uh taiwan i think even though actually i
feel it works it doesn't mean that i'm
gonna run up to you and force it in your
nose
exactly you have a dirty nose yeah
although what being without
waterboarding wouldn't be a bad idea it
wouldn't be like wow this is this is
very effective you know what just as a
thank you i think i'll give you the
information you need
so go to uh xclare.com for more info and
really i recommend you read the uh the
literature the scientific data okay so
uh last week let's this is something we
really want
russia the ukraine but more specifically
what's happening with russia and china
yeah
i was watching uh former vice president
biden's very short speech for the
largest military action taken since
world war ii
in one country against another i was
like really that was that was it that
was his speech it was very very brief
but when i watched it and i heard what
he was saying
and i want to get to then it forced me
to do some digging i immediately was
concerned that ah
this seems like the kind of play
that could force russia into a corner to
create
some kind of an alliance or partnership
with with china and and see if you can
understand why i might have
thought that last week
mr president you didn't mention swift in
your sanctions that you announced is
there a reason why the u.s
isn't doing that is there disagreement
among allies um regarding swift and
whether
russia should be allowed to be a part of
it
the sanctions that we've proposed on all
their banks of equal consequence maybe
more consequence than swift number one
number two
uh it is always an option but right now
that's not the position that the rest of
uh europe wishes to take okay
so he's been talking about the economic
sanctions which by the way is not nearly
as severe
as still still buying oil yes we're
still doing that okay okay making sure
yeah eight hundred and twenty five
thousand barrels a day roughly fifty
something okay yeah just making sure you
give them six hours to fire putin
here's the thing and i'm gonna talk
about this before we finish this segment
because a lot of us said what should we
do and they always look to what we can
do internationally you can't control
what other countries do there's a lot
that we can do here at home and so for
all of us faults donald trump took
actions here at home to make sure that
we would be less affected by this
[ __ ] okay just to be clear there are
still actions that we can take right now
that would not only hurt russia but
would help americans help mitigate the
damage done to everyday americans but
that's really not of concern to this
president so
there are practical solutions that we
should all be on board with of course we
can't because there really isn't a
middle when people try to say i'm a
centrist no there's a radical left and
there's a big
old right wing tent that's what you've
got right now think about and i mean
that for a second before i'm going with
a segment people always say
oh well you know it's actually the
extremists on the right cpac just
happened yeah if you look at the list of
speakers you look at the list of people
that you have people like a donald trump
and then you have libertarians but you
have people who believe that black tar
heroine should be legal and should be a
state issue and then you have people who
are basically mennonites this is the
right wing on the left
you're excoriated if you're simply
liberal and you can't be liberal and
pro-life
you can't be allowed on the liberal
platform and pro-gun bernie sanders when
he was in a primary had to justify why
he was the only person on that stage to
not get an f from the nra he only
achieved a d minus and he had to
apologize how is that for ridgid okay
so concerned that obviously this can
start driving rush into the arms of
china why because when you put these
economic sanctions on them they need to
have some kind of business alliances
some kind of financial interest
that's a dangerous place i mean i get
that it's a sticky situation here's the
thing
it continued well actually i think i
think this actually happened then biden
said put my name on there like with the
nordstrom
pipeline leave me a place to sign but
european uh commission president ursula
von
der lane
ursula von der layne
hopefully you didn't swedish chef
then announced that they would expel
russian banks from the swift system
i will now propose to eu leaders the
following measures first
we commit to ensuring that a certain
number of russian banks are removed from
swift
this will ensure
that these banks are disconnected from
the international financial system
and harm the ability to operate globally
swift is the world's dominant global
interbank payment system
cutting banks off
will stop them from conducting most of
their financial transactions worldwide
and effectively block russian exports
and imports and she went on to sing a
beat us in goodnight audition does mr
belding know that exactly the speech
[Laughter]
mr building
cut them out from the swift banks
[Laughter]
so white house uh canada uk did the same
thing and then what happened immediately
after this gerald you're a learned man
well uh putin of course backed down and
left ukraine had in hand no no he uh he
he took it one step further and he
actually put his nuclear forces on alert
yeah right this is based on the
presumption that russia won't like like
oh no you're going to remove our ability
to bank legitimately internationally
it's almost like you're following
protocol of drug war but following on
international diplomacy where will i
make my revenue oh no
well my nuke runs on quarters yes what
will i do
it used to run on um dimes but inflation
is a [ __ ] for all of us yes
the oil is very expensive it also
accepts 50 million rupees my tanks take
premium but it's hard to fit in slot
oh my gosh well i feel like look you do
have to step up sanctions right you
don't just go all the way to the very
end first and cutting them off from
swift that's a big deal especially when
in russia they were facing some really
high inflation i think it was somewhere
around nine or ten percent
barely above the united states i've
heard numbers from nine all the way up
to twenty just now
for people who don't know swift it's an
international it was an international uh
like a rapid
banking system
so each loaf of bread will be nine
percent less as big well no no that's
not how quite that sounds nightmarish
but so inflation goes up right so what
is the fed thinking about doing here in
the united states well they're thinking
about raising interest rates well the
problem with that is that there's only
so many things you can do and just this
morning the russian national or the the
russian central bank sorry i was going
to say national bank was actually cut
off so now they don't have the tools
basically they freeze all the assets
that are held here in the united states
united states citizens and businesses
right cannot do business there anymore
right and so now russia's backed into
even a further corner right and so a man
like putin goes all right i'm backed
into a corner you didn't think i was
going to come over the top of your raise
i'm saying nuclear missiles right high
alert right now your move yeah these
these sanctions are
just as severe as war someone asked them
i think a question would you say these
are severe as the dead ukrainians like
more more it's worse
what
you can you know you can't you can't buy
happiness but you know you can't bring a
dead kid back so
it's like the money is you know it's the
south it's it'll work what are you
saying i want to kill my kids yeah well
this this has created a problem
this has created a problem where now
goods are more expensive and also the
value of the ruble has dropped like 30
about 30 and so he met at a really long
table if you watch any news channel
you'll see him at this like table they
should stop producing really long tables
and maybe focus on the economy yes we're
producing jobs yeah he's got like a
70-foot table and two people on the
other hand mr putin we have that
financial airport stop we are a
lengthening table
we need more people bob i can't vote you
you keep this i can't focus on how long
i will make table go get make yourself
useful get tape measurer and a solid
block of oak send them to the left
dinner with kim basinger
batman i'll just come down there all
right
bring my gruel you know i don't think
i've ever been in this room yeah so
so basically they didn't let their stock
market open they didn't want the ruble
to continue to fall but as it devalues
in in world currency right they're less
able to manage this crisis and so that's
what we're talking about creating an
issue like the treaty of versailles
which you said it pushed two people who
had been at war with each other russia
and germany during world war one into
being allies
very very quickly after that and so in
world war ii that's why they started out
on the same team until hitler attacked
russia right he would have been on the
same team with a guy for a little longer
that's the same thing that can happen
with china right right so you're now
pushing people who naturally can be a
little bit of that's a really really
good point because a lot of people say
well a lot of people have said
actually that uh well it's not really a
concern because you know putin is really
anti-communist which i don't know uh i
mean i think he says it but okay uh i
don't necessarily know that i trust him
i do believe that he is he is concerned
more with russia's national interest i
do believe yeah now i believe he's
concerned with russia's national
interests uh at the cost of certain
russians not only other members of well
of eastern europe uh but this is also
important to note where you're talking
about you can push people who would be
natural enemies into becoming friends
putin right russia they've stockpiled
just to be clear 630 billion dollars of
uh international foreign currency yeah
exactly and 14 of that is held in china
right right and so it may not be
convenient most of the time for these
guys to be friends but if you're backed
into a corner and you have no way out
you you tend to go to somebody who can
help and they're close right so russia
is the largest producer of wheat in the
world i didn't really know this i knew
they were pretty high up there well
technically it's true we are the largest
producer but no there's a name let's
talk about look at that
[Laughter]
was that donald trump there no no i
couldn't see who was at the end of the
table
is that no we built the tables then we
built the room around it yes it was like
come on guys
hey president trump [ __ ] you guys
send it down to him come over here and
say to my face i don't have the time the
table is filled with wheat it's quite so
big yes it's also act as a great
insulator it's a vacuum sealed with
wheat yeah exactly what a stupid table
well that's how they measure dicks in
russia is these giant stupid and how far
you can put people you need to be able
to pass papers between down the table he
just walks over to he's just walking
over to the white house he's like
okay can you pass the pepper do you
think i have the time yes 15 feet that's
not fair i'm not unemployed i am busy
man
hold on let me ask a slave on stilts hey
brave on stilts yes bring me choo choo
to saw password yes i asked for long
table
bomb
this is the smallest table i've ever
said
this is not you call this dining room
table this is like coffee table what is
this
this is like this in russia is
nightstand oh my god i put my feet on it
to watch television yeah it's a meeting
room
who's going to be intimidated by that
okay well look let me get back to russia
so the other than the long table nine
weeks to poison the guest
all right so wheat
hold on
if i drink your milkshake
[Laughter]
take this
can you catch the can
he's got like a video he's got a screen
down there he's like can you set up
camera and put on tv next to me
i need to be head of table but i can't
hear you i cannot hear him are you
rolling your eyes are you hey uh talk
miss uh miss uh miss glenn close uh look
alike talk into speaker yes you have to
hit talk i can't hear you how's that
grand home lady who threatened me to
come closer yes yes yes uh i will uh i
will wait for her by setting by sitting
calendar all right go ahead no but
obviously they're also known for natural
gas longer than our winters
that's how you know it's good
that's how you know it's good it's
hilarious i mean it's just it really is
the funniest table i've ever seen so the
company behind the gas prom right so the
biggest oil company their natural gas
producer which was stolen by the state
by the way from private company what i'm
not going to get into that yeah they're
the company behind the nordstrom 2
pipeline they signed in february a
30-year deal with russia to pump in gas
right so china and russia now have a
deal a 30-year deal yeah and russia is
already china's second largest oil
supplier right so china is getting tons
of resources from these guys and i just
told you about the wheat just a second
ago they just opened up a deal that they
had signed i think about a month or two
ago they just fast tracked it so they
could get more wheat into china right so
there's you know in 2021 the trade
between these two countries was a record
150 built 150 billion in the next two or
three years they want to be at 200
billion that's not so just to be blunt
this right but it is going to help but
to be clear
again they're not necessarily people
would say they're not natural allies now
i unders but it's not like there's this
embargo like it's an entirely cold it's
not like it's an entirely frigid
relationship they are trading parts
they're strengthening ties and they are
strengthening ties right now and this is
what happens when you if you just
if you just try and [ __ ] someone
economically
those without any kind of military
action it's a half in measure and these
people have to find some kind of a lot
they have to exactly they have to find
an alliance and right now china of
course is the one who wants to greet
them with open arms right um and that's
to lane's point the other day he's right
that if you do this to russia they will
get closer to china and that's a big
problem because every single issue that
we face geopolitically whether it's your
the climate change accords or whatever
we're trying to do china is always the
wild card i i am warming up to china but
i keep them at tables length
it's actually safer for the people at
the table
yeah exactly i need north stream
pipeline to bring guests through table
that's how they bring that gift to putin
is a longer table yes longer table
how many tables is your pipeline yes
we would like to present this gift to uh
vladimir putin it's just they have like
dr seuss who characters yeah
we get a statue of liberty from france
they get a long table from china we need
to four more liberty ships to bring that
i like when my dinner is presented in
silver tray that is opened with smaller
person in tray and then smaller person
for two miles
then it's reached me and i go oh it's
troubling
that's our food i would shoot you from
this table but from this distance the
bullet would stray no who am i an
olympian
so um here's also something important
china is supporting right now russia
diplomatically they've made it pretty
damn clear the chinese foreign ministry
spokesperson
discussed western sanctions saying that
this is uh there's some quotes china
always opposes any illegal unilateral
sanctions the u.s has imposed more than
100 sanctions on russia since 2011 which
not only failed to solve the issue but
also harm the legitimate rights and
interests of others this is not just uh
the foreign ministry hong kong yang i
just people always hold me the standard
of saying the names properly i don't
care i'm american i almost said chun li
yeah all right i will when he can
pronounce stephen crowder that's two r's
you have an idea how impossible that is
so um
the top diplomat in china also uh
made these statements or expressed these
statements i guess i have to say to be
careful with the german foreign minister
uh china disapproves of the use of
sanctions to solve problems still less
unilateral sanctions that have no basis
in inter international law and there's
plenty of evidence too beyond this
beyond just what they've said official
chinese spokespersons and beyond what we
see in the hundreds of billions of
dollars in trade and beyond what we see
in these growing stronger ties uh well
there's more to it than that yeah
they've actually refused to call this an
invasion i think it they're calling it
uh they just went for a walk in another
country yes with uh weapons yeah he
walking his dog around the table yeah
what are you doing and then uh hoyway
actually is is training uh i think 50
000 russians in cyber defense because
right now the cyber attacks are probably
pretty high on russia obviously they
were dealing with some of that and i
just talked about the wheat restrictions
a minute ago like that's that's a big
deal i just kind of dropped them they
just dropped them but do you know what
also is one of the biggest uh kind of
products of ukraine wheat
right so it's they were they were known
as the bread basket of the soviet union
so to speak um and so there's a lot of
ties to this so china is doing
everything that whole place sounds
terrible well wheat doesn't sound bad
well technically we have biggest supply
of wheat in world but
20 to 98 is used for vodka well but have
you seen the wheat around chernobyl
oh it's really large stocks yes but
unfortunately you can go fifth nipple
yeah third fifth now you become
superheroes it wins you a prize at a
four very dead does my goiter look
swollen
[Laughter]
all right
well you know the point is this is
getting pretty this is getting really
bad significant yeah the idea of a china
russia alliance
especially as we've talked about taiwan
yeah um that is world war iii
that is world war iii if that kind of a
superpower
is created not saying
we're there yet but the signs are here
diplomatically economically there have
been major changes and now you have
a country that is
really hell-bent on wanting to be a
world superpower right there's a lot of
saber-rattling and they also want to be
independent and not beholden to these
international committees which i can
understand the sentiment of that
uh
being forced to prove that they're a
superpower yeah after if someone starts
saying like screaming that they're a
superpower what you wanted is like yeah
yeah your superpower we get it
and you move on yeah i'm like you don't
want to say no you're not right i'll
show you the way till i get to that
other side of the table yeah when you
have a billion people just in one
country well several mad men well and
it's a totally different thing that if
you bring china into this equation
everything changes immediately
immediately for the entire world like
the rest of the world against russia
would be a hard fight potentially
potentially how bad this could go he has
a napoleonic complex and we're like hey
we're going to sanction your banks and
he's like here's
you want me to push
and xi
is shorter than actual napoleon well yes
yeah so and they have admitted yeah when
you have a royal flush make sure you
fold immediately yeah
so here's the thing even the chinese
internet is cheering putin on
her husband
that's smoking chinese man next thing
you know you're gonna tell me to put
nine crates of chickens on a honda cub
yeah here can't happen here's the thing
now i also understand what some of you
are thinking
okay before you comment although it does
help the algorithm so comment below
whatever it is but yeah before you say
it yes that probably is chinese
propaganda but that makes it worse that
makes it worse because tick tock just so
you know we've talked about this they
favor chinese propaganda post right any
nationalist posts for china things that
come down from the ccp and some of these
influencers are paid here you're paid to
promote yoga pants or tea or whatever
the hell it is and it's probably bogus
tea that doesn't work to help you lose
weight over there you're paid to promote
the government and then tick tock favors
you so it it's worse if that is chinese
propaganda i'm not saying that i didn't
watch it and go
this seems like it might be scripted
also i could see the reflection in the
window of the guy holding a gun to his
head but
exactly i thought it would be a creative
choice chinese women rarely i feel like
she was speaking from the heart yes yeah
i feel like that was something that she
was forced to say yeah well exactly
you're not free to speak period in china
but for some reason now she has an
opinion on war strategy yeah and her
idol
such a handsome like you that's why you
know she's scared
he's very handsome oh he's so big and
he's so handsome he's so big he's
handsome have have a very big tick table
please let me keep
just one of my babies please let me keep
up so by the way also a translation of
one of putin's uh speeches yeah got one
i had to reread this was this a was this
a
misprint 1.1 billion views on weibo in
24 hours wow
that's insane
that's a lot of views
1.1 billion views you can get 1.1
billion views on almost anything
ever and putin's speech is going to get
that just a translation it's like a
seventh of the world or something and
here's something else we're talking
about the missteps that have been taken
don't forget that uh uh former vice
president biden had the bright idea
of sharing us intel on russian troops
with who
let me draw it on the ground we are here
uh-huh they're there
hold on a second let me let me draw you
a map
mapping a list of my schedule and
hobbies yeah i told china i didn't think
they were going to use it against it
yeah i don't think how many artillery
pieces did you say oh yeah yeah it's
like all right we're having a sit we're
having a sit down geraldo former vice
president biden thank you for being here
you have a problem with over sharing
yeah
well i thought i was caring that's why i
told him i had six hours okay stop
admitting to crimes
i didn't i said i was the big guy you
said i i am the big guy son of a [ __ ]
oh here we go stop just shut up so this
will never be charged yeah this is from
the new york times over three months
senior biden administration officials
held half a dozen urgent meetings with
top chinese officials in which the
americans presented intelligence showing
russia's troop buildup around ukraine
another quote u.s officials got
intelligence showing beijing had shared
the information
immediately with moscow
telling the russians that the united
states was trying to sow discord
oh
no
it's like we're our own worst enemies
it's a game of international telephone
with nukes ah yes
it's like america knows they're just
being babysit by their grandpa or like
the country the world just is like oh
this this dude has dementia yeah our
babysitter we just do whatever we want
here's the thing chaos i also i've said
this before i can see arguments on
almost all i try to on all sides of the
issue for example i'm pro-life but i
understand that people who may not
understand the science behind
fertilization dna they don't believe
that i can understand why someone holds
that position i can understand why some
i don't agree with it i can understand
why someone holds a position of you know
abortion for rape and outside of you
know rape and incest or sorry abortion
for rape and insulin the exception i
don't necessarily agree with it i
understand it i can understand why some
people who are uneducated on the idea of
net
transfers
from federal income tax maybe think that
people need to pay their fair share i
can understand
that i don't agree with it but i can
understand why someone might maintain
these positions there are some scenarios
i i can't and maybe you can comment and
let me know i've always said this
charter schools
the
school choice the idea of school choice
i've never heard an argument that is
logical or convincing meaning one that i
even believe someone who's arguing that
position namely being anti-school choice
one that they believe yeah i don't
understand here
the argument
that former vice president had like how
would he present the case for why
sharing with china intel
on the russian troop buildup was a good
idea
you got me
it's uh any purpose not i don't think um
seriously i'm not paying physicians can
anyone think of why no i think he's
literally no i really do think he's
naive i think he thinks we have a
standing with the global community right
now that we don't have and he's going to
china thinking all right we're going to
keep china on our side by doing this and
china's just laughing at him they've
been laughing at him since he was before
he was elected right
right yeah he's not afraid well i don't
know if he's not afraid of them he's
just not aware of anything and they know
it yeah
he thinks he's more powerful than he is
yeah that's the sad part is where
i mean if they become an alliance
we're losing our power right well
absolutely and i i don't that's the
reality i don't know that i mean china
is for me china would do some of the
same kind of stupid at least fighting
over the power maybe some guy just spoke
really good english and said he was
hunter
yeah
just keeps calling them for information
hello dad
how you doing
no but this really this really huncher
it's you again this sounds different i
have a call
it's because i've been taking care of
the banks here
thanks for the job big guy
the problem with this is that all of
this is a joke but this is how these
scenarios spin out of control because
you have people who misread the
situation and don't understand power and
don't understand people that have power
and actually exercising it i'm sorry joe
biden you are not powerful
somebody like vladimir putin or somebody
like xi jinping who is a an autocrat or
a dictator former kgb guy they may not
be powerful in ways that we like but
they wield power or at least
people that disagree with them they
understand it's terrible right they
understand it and they are only
threatened and here's the thing
inherently someone uh as opposed to
being naive inherently someone who is
willing to commit acts of evil which you
would have to admit egb oh of course
evil of course that is someone who has
to understand human nature to understand
the idea of power you have to understand
human nature you look at xi jinping you
can look at the genocide that's being
committed and just to be clear this is
me actually being fair
former vice president joe biden has done
nothing to that degree no okay not
knowingly committing an act of evil to
this degree he called him a killer he
knows putin's that guy right he knows
putin is that guy in this scenario but
the issue is
people who understand and value power
have to understand human nature what
does that mean they understand that
human beings are inherently bad are
inherently selfish if not curb that's
where faith comes in that's the idea of
you know original sin the idea of a
fallen man right this is some people who
base their life and this is one thing
with you know a lot of people think that
the left is inherently more
compassionate it's predicated on the
idea that people are inherently
good that people will inherently be
altruistic that oh wait a second yeah if
you give more money to the government of
course people are inherently good good
will be done with that money we know
that's not true wait people are
inherently good let's share intel on
russian troop build-ups with china
whereas they're laughing because these
are people who willingly commit genocide
these are people who willingly arrest
punk rock bands and murder people and
get the olympics in both cases yeshua
and china and both
were doping wow it's not even close the
no no the russians were dope i don't
give a rap
if somebody
what is russia going to do they're going
to what jump across that table at me
they not only were doping if you guys
watch this documentary icarus it's
fascinating it's hilarious too they
weren't even people thought the russians
beat this is how evil the russians are
there was a russian anti-doping
commission i believe which which means
the russian doping commission yeah take
anti yeah yes by the way what we call it
russian
anti-doping commission but i think you
can read between the lines maybe that i
scratched out with line anti am i clear
okay i go back to my side of the table
so
not only were they co2 yes co2 tuesday
he just starts going across the theme
from lawrence
[Laughter]
still walking they
they not only were doping people think
like oh they would cycle off steroids to
beat the test no no the russians were so
hell bent on doping that they actually
found it would they had trapped doors
where they would freeze peoples they
would freeze p yeah p people's plural
yeah i'm using it right they would
freeze folks i'll use that
clean urine from like months or years
ago so that they could immediately up
until competition still be using obscene
amounts of performance-enhancing drugs
because that's not the urine that they
were using
well it's not so it's not the same as
beating a test enough when it comes to
the united states where you cycle on you
cycle off you have to be subtle there
are kind of ways to find things that
maybe aren't like you know crazy
steroids and performance-ending drugs
but maybe things that might be such a
small amount you micro dose no they were
just going go absolutely crazy and we
will then freeze your piece from two
years ago well
that seems like fine stuff to do and
they also found a way to get the the
little cam thing the canisters open yes
they had they had locks on them that
were supposed to be impenetrable and
they're like ah yes we figured out how
to open them and then replace them that
would have honestly been my plan in high
school yeah like i don't know man you
want to let's go to russia freeze your
piss yeah that's clean
let's get some frozen piss and then we
can just put it in the jar no they'll
watch you pee yeah oh man yeah well look
i guess we're in trouble well the thing
is that's not how i worked in russia
because we're going to the entertainment
commission
this is great you have good ideas now of
course you will compete clean you will
go in there and provide urine sample
while opening trap door to take urine
simple yeah enjoy am i clear
do you understand do i need to spell it
out for you
keep taking all the drugs yeah never
stop yeah well and really quickly i know
russia china bad right and a lot of
people have said we've been kind of
elevating ukraine to a level that maybe
we shouldn't there's there's a lot of
there's a lot of negative stuff there
there's a lot of corruption but the way
that they are you can also argue that it
was kind of a puppet installment obama
yeah yeah but the way that they are
fighting right now the citizens of
ukraine like i know there's a lot of
fake information going around on you
know twitter social media everywhere
even you know news organizations like
cnn but i'm impressed by zielinski and
i'm impressed by the fight that they are
putting up yeah and so i want to make
sure like we i don't know if anybody i
don't know i know they have starlink now
from elon musk i know that he just put
internet there and it's like hey this
this is a fantastic development i don't
know if anybody watches from there but
like i think the rest of the world
except for the [ __ ] in china are on
your side like you're you are the the
underdog in this fight and you guys are
doing an amazing job from what we see
the human beings the citizens right yeah
just like you separate the chinese
citizens from the communist chinese
party right correct i hate
the chinese government because i have
empathy for the chinese citizens i'm not
a huge fan of the way the ukraine
government was installed i'm not a huge
fan of what their what their
what their alignments are
because i also don't think that's what
benefits the ukrainian people just to be
clear but the people who are standing
there and fighting this is it is your
heart has to go out for these
go out to these people you have to be
inspired by their bravery and you also
have to be terrified look
i think it's pretty uh now they're
trying to blame donald trump you saw
mitt romney yeah for russia i think it's
pretty clear with russia right we look
we talk about georgia right we talk
about crimea now we talk about ukraine
you're basically talking about kids who
were fooling around in class until the
tough teacher were like
yeah
donald trump walked by for three years
then
and they go right back to acting up i
think we've all seen that happen now if
you want to argue that's a delayed
reaction and this is what i think when i
want to leave you with this a silver
well two things what we can do here at
home in a silver lining okay silver
lining here
they always try to argue right any time
something would happen that was good or
that was bad with obama they would blame
him on george bush and then anytime
something that would something would
happen that was good or positive with
donald trump they would try and give
credit to obama
the silver lining is about eight years
of barack obama we saw how russian acted
we had three years of donald trump and
now you're back to four years of former
vice president biden it's pretty tough
to make that argument twice
in other words it's pretty tough to go
and say all the good that happened under
trump was because of obama and now say
yeah but actually really the russia
thing is trump's fault but you just said
the good that happened under trump was
barack obama because there were eight
years
three and i say three years because the
presidency was completely kneecapped by
the left yeah uh because of covet and
now we're back and immediately we're
back to how it was for eight years this
contrast is really valuable and there
are people who are waking up right now
not just in the united states but
ukraine russia allows you to wake people
up across the world it doesn't take a
genius to figure out eight years three
and then within the first year year and
a half we're right back to old habits
that is a good thing we've never in our
lifetime had the ability to have the
contrast of
eight years a sh a stark departure with
donald trump not even
basically a republican until he ran
right
uh and then right back to the same
person who was former vice president
same exact administration especially
when you see the exact same kinds of
results economically internationally
look we had george w bush okay lots of
wars barack obama more drone strikes
than any president continued the wars
donald trump
only president modern american history
to not start new wars
vine comes enough now we're right back
and already oh i guarantee we're going
to be in some kind of a war here before
his first term is up assuming that he
makes it that long
he kind of went the barack obama route
with the fire insurance and bringing in
kamala hey who can i pick this vp uh
we've selected the person who pulled
dead last in every democratic primary
well done bingo
what else what's what can we do here a
lot of people think about and i would
love to hear you know again best thing
for the algorithm is comment
uh because this is genuine
it's always easy to just criticize and
[ __ ] and not offer any constructive
solutions now i'm not in charge of
domestic policy however what i am saying
is people who are in charge of domestic
policy i know that you're watching the
show there are a lot of people out there
legislators right representatives who
watch this show
um
we don't have to be dependent on russia
at all
for energy that affects americans to a
dramatic degree we're talking about
inflation we're talking about gas prices
not just gas prices you're talking about
in general just globally petroleum
products you're talking about in general
energy
costs not just gas we do not have to be
uh
we do not have to be dependent on a lot
of these international uh relationships
for hard goods and services
we can do a lot of this here in the
united states if we open it up now it's
hard to get you can get into okay
textiles and steel and lumber right a
lot of people don't realize this 80
percent do you know this 80 of a lot of
american
or beef in american grocery stores is
not from the united states of america
brazil
i don't know where i mean i just know
that it's not from the united states of
america which i mean
surprised we're in texas
have you been to it's nothing but cattle
seen yellowstone there's cattle
everywhere how does this happen
nebraska's got some cows i've seen it
yeah i've seen it with my own eyes i've
heard about it not to mention why are we
buying corn from anywhere it's on the
welcome to indiana state sign don't stop
too well after des moines i seen it with
these eyes
and then it says indiana we're more than
corn that's what it says with a picture
of corn
more corn we we need to make sure that
we present we have so much corn here in
indiana we need to uh we need to let
people know that we're more than current
what should we do show them the corn
nebraska's like we're corn huskers we're
going to go overboard
yeah there's no need to be dependent on
foreign nations this is the idea of
america first because guess what you
need to put on your own oxygen mask
before you help somebody else america
first is also what's best for not only
the american citizens but what is best
for these other countries this it's a
failed experiment
the idea of no international borders the
idea of all cultures are alike and we
can hold hands and sing we are the world
because guess what
it just requires one evil prick as we
now see and we got two evil pricks right
now we just need one to ruin it for
everybody else and oh my gosh it's not
like there's been a precedent set
for that
all throughout human history so there
are things that we can do and there are
things that our representatives can do
and look what can you do you can get
active and you know what make sure you
remember this when you vote make sure
you file this in your brain that little
chip whenever you go forward
that mean tweets don't really mean that
much
is that fair all right you guys can come
up we're gonna uh take your chats uh of
course on mug club and play oh we're
playing razer robot
oh there's no way we can do this on
youtube so youtube you know what go
ahead and fact check the vaccine stuff
we don't give a rat's ass piss off
you